it's time for the long gene Khurana
scope a television journal of the
important issues of the hour brought to
you every Monday Wednesday and Fridays a
presentation of the lawn gene wit nor
watch company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching chrono scope from the CBS
television news staff larry lesser and
George Herman our distinguished guests
for this evening is Harvey V higly
administrator of Veterans Affairs now
even these days when wars and the
threats of wars jumping us from every
headline an unfortunate irony holds true
it's a fact that when a man returns from
war he's a conquering hero and it's also
a fact that after he's been back for a
few years his former hero worshippers
many of them regard him as just another
tax burden now that veterans
administrator not only has a vast
administrative problem but he also has
to do a public-relations job between
Congress and the veteran and mr. Hickey
when you took over your job you were
given four billion dollars by Congress
to do it now has that been enough money
yes
mr. Lasser if you take into
consideration that we were given two
hundred millions as a supplemental
contribution this last session of
Congress you need to pay the bills that
you couldn't pay these are they be here
the contractual obligations to those men
who have pensions or compensation coming
it's the contract between the government
and those men and of course it has to be
paid well mr. greevy you entered the
veterans post during a period when
Congress is very economy minded now have
you been able to save money or have they
been just as generous with you as they
were with the previous veterans
administrator I can't answer about the
previous administrators they have been
very fair with us we at the present time
we could use some more money it's true
but I do think they try to give us the
money that we need to do our job well
that brings up another question talking
about your job if you have the money and
you're doing it how about the veterans
how do they feel now for instance in
Korea I noticed that a great many of the
GIS there were very bitter they felt
that they were Forgotten men now has
your organization been able to make them
feel that they're not forgotten that
they're remembered by a grateful country
well mr. Herman I'm Frank to say that I
I haven't seen any evidences of that
bitterness since they came back now I
would venture to guess however that when
they do come home and they're out of
service and they're given these
opportunities in education on a home and
the other benefits that may be involved
particularly if they are disabled or in
trouble in some respect to physical
trouble that would certainly make them
feel much more kindly if they did in the
past have a feeling that they were
forgotten men over in Korea take the
tomorrow I think is going to be the
tenth anniversary of the GI Bill of
Rights now do you think that bill has
been a success or has a lot of money
been wasted I I think it has been a
great success I I rather glad you asked
that question I'd like to answer it in
this way any law that's put on the books
is written to take care of the greatest
number of men in this case veterans and
as far as words go they they do the best
job they can to make it fit however I
don't believe there's a law on the books
today that doesn't have at its two
extremes either those that do not seem
to benefit properly or at the other end
perhaps those who seem to get a benefit
to which they're not entitled so on the
local level whether it's a matter of
education or benefits pensions
compensation whatever it may be
hospitalization we do have the feeling
on the part of some people that for
veterans are getting a free ride because
they know somebody down the street or
somebody they're acquainted with who is
apparently not entitled as far as they
know to what he's getting I think
everyone should realize that laws play
the average and I will say that for the
average the GI Bill of Rights has been
of inestimable value to a very large
number of veterans and that this country
has gained materially because they had a
GI Bill of Rights well now you have a
new law which is a sort of a an
offspring of the Bill of Rights that is
the law dealing with it's a sort of Bill
of Rights for Korean veterans as that a
same law is that a new improved law
which is the same law except that in
some instances it works out a little
differently it a little bit different
but the men substantially get all of the
same benefit is it more efficient more
streamlined better better from an
administrative standpoint that's degree
of course under Selective Service now
about a half a million men are entering
the army every year entering the Armed
Forces now this means that as far as we
can foresee into the future under the
present international situation we're
going to have a nation of increasing
number of veterans and moreover they are
now thinking about a universal military
training law which would take every boy
in after the age of 18 for a long period
of service
can we actually afford to go on with the
the benefits that we are giving our
veterans if the number of veterans
increase it's going to cost more money
to take care of them of course you
understand that as far as the Veterans
Administration is concerned we're only
interested in veterans and only wartime
veterans peacetime veterans if for
instance the Korea War or whatever it is
the Korea what war here is the war as it
was still there's an oasis there there's
still no peace in Korea so everyone who
was in inducted now here comes a war
veteran he is a Korean veter as far as
we're concerned the Korean War is going
on and as long as that's true all of the
men who are now serving will be in
these benefits if I Harbor tomorrow or
some day the president I presume would
decree or Congress that the war shall be
considered at an end
then from anybody who went into the
service beyond that date would be a
peacetime veteran and we would mister do
you think that the Communists are trying
to break this country by refusing to
sign a peace treaty in Korea so everyone
is a war veteran well I think they have
a lot of ways of trying to break us that
may be one of them well how does the war
of the war period is there a cut-off or
does the war period run indefinitely and
if there should be an armistice
certified so that we would declare that
the war in Korea whatever you want to
call it is over does that mean that
after a certain length of time all
benefits will cease not all benefits but
benefits like your education and
training and your loan guarantee and and
though that type but of course the
matter of pensions and compensation and
hospitalization have to do with the
man's situated the veteran a man or
woman that person's situation at any
given time and he does not lose any of
his right if something that develops in
later years he's still a better and he's
still entitled to consideration mr. Lee
we've heard it said that there are a lot
of veterans hospitals being built
since the end of the last war and
everyone knows that at the conclusion of
a war politicians do go in and ask for
hospitals to be built in there among
their constituents now I understand a
lot of hospitals are built but do you
haven't got the money or the personnel
to man them is this actually the case no
that isn't quite right mr. LeSueur this
how the hospitals which we are now
activating were started as a program
immediately after World War two and in
fact were practically at the end of that
program and we'll end up with a hundred
and seventy four hospitals I
I won't say anything about politicians I
might venture to say however that
unfortunately hospitals were put in poor
locations by some hooker crook and we're
finding it extremely difficult to stack
them at those hospitals and in fact they
are also located where you do not have
the
patterns where there where the veteran
load it does not exist well why are you
having us difficulty in staffing these
hospitals because you don't pay the
medical officers whom you would like to
get enough to go into a Veterans
Hospital well there are two reasons
where we are short of certain types of
medical assistants as for instance
psychiatrists there just are not enough
psychiatrist in the country and it
doesn't matter much how much you pay you
can't hire them you can't find them now
the the doctors are paid somewhat on a
scale like your civil service it is not
the same scale but it works in the
public law of 293 set up how their two
paid also nurses and of course that's
all we can pay and and that's all right
that's all right because we've got to
take potluck along with everybody else
you know we we cannot be in a position
where we can take more than our just
share there's got to be competition in
it so all needs for hospital care mental
jason is there are there more mental
cases among veterans than there are
among the rest of the population
no I am told by those who really should
know that within the same age group the
number of mental cases among non
veterans is just as great as veterans
I'd like to ask you another question
about those the veterans who served in
the were actually exposed to communist
brainwashing in the prisoner of war
camps in in North Korea and Communist
China now are you doing anything
especially for those chaps that is under
discussion I don't believe that those
men are veterans at the present time now
they may be but until the army or Navy
or Marines or Air Force discharged them
they are not veteran so they we would
have nothing to do with them there is a
considerable discussion among those who
might enter that picture to be sure that
the job is very well done and we have
frankly made the suggestion that we be
permitted
to take that on as our job so that
because we probably will have more
contact with them than than many others
well I just have a few seconds to ask
you a question has modern war like the
Korean War in which my colleague George
Herman was active so law and has modern
war resulted in more people becoming
completely disabled so that they are
forced to be supported by the government
I would I would say yes for the reason
that as mr. Herman pointed out when we
were talking before we came in here
about his service over there so many of
these men were saved by helicopter
service getting them back from the front
lines and all that they were saved but
unfortunately they will not be able to
take their rightful place in society or
work and so they may be those that we
will have to take care of for a long
time that's sad news but thank you very
much for coming here and telling us mr.
Hamish the opinions expressed on the
lawn Jane crow no scope were those of
the speakers the editorial board for
this edition of the launching Cronus
Cove waz Larry no sir and George Herman
our distinguished guest was Harvey V
Higley administrator of Veterans Affairs